this is a tough tight rope to walk
they've already started promoting
obviously jim carrey
as joe biden i am involved in politics
my rudolph is senator harris it's such
an honor to be
involved in any presidential race and i
mean geez this one
this one's a real doozy uh alec baldwin
as donald trump
we're ripping out all the vegetables in
michelle obama's garden and planting
mcnuggets
i could just take one really bad joke to
step over that line and they'll be in a
lot of trouble
it's a cast adept at improv and a source
tells e.t
parts of the live show are written as
late as friday night
so yeah there's time to tweak and change
based on the news
snl will not have a problem here in
terms of flipping the script
and moving forward with what everybody
is talking about they're gonna be
testing a lot of jokes
through the night i'm just gonna have
fun and see if i can get some viral
moments
mama needs a gif what's the trick to
really nailing
the kamala i definitely tried to make
her fun she has
no problem speaking her mind and there's
another coveted issue snl is grappling
with
the safety of its cast and audience as
the show returns to its studio at 30
rock
hey i'm chris rock and i'm hosting the
season premiere of snl this week with
musical guest megan the stallion
show's gonna be great we're not even
worried right megan
nope it's weird man you get tested
pretty much every day
everyone has a mask on every some people
have double shields on
snl audience members will have to pass
temperature checks
they'll also be rapid testing for covet
19 and will be required to wear mass
those are the right precautions those
are the right protocols i would put in a
laugh track instead because if even
one person comes down with the virus
after they see this show
it'll be as bad a pr that snl has ever
[Music]
received